i'd like to address something uh here
briefly for the first time in quite a
while
everyone and i mean everyone not just
business bros
everyone is talking about wall street
and the stock market
you probably already know this but a
group of small stock traders got
together on the website
reddit and decided to buy stock in a
company called gamestop
which then caused some big-time hedge
funds to lose billions
of dollars well anyway i think that's
the basic gist of what's been happening
and i have to say it's fascinating that
a small bunch of people on an internet
message board
can have such a huge impact on the stock
market
what do you think andy i said sell now
buy
oh hey conan yeah none of the gamestop
controversy surprised me
i predicted it all on my show i'm sorry
what show
this show andy richter's cuckoo cash
welcome back to cookie cash where i go
cuckoo to make you
cash before we start i've got just a
little business to attend to
buy sell buy sell bell
sigh shout out goodbye
hey conan yeah i just made a million
bucks
lost it all made it back and then lost
most of it again
and that's a profit of 30 bucks
congratulations andy
now let's get cuckoo with some stocked
photos
about stocks
this stock photo made me worried but
this stock photo made me feel better
and this stock photo made me hungry
now let's go to cuckoo cash
corresponding conan o'brien with some
hilarious stock sticker symbols
thanks andy here's some hilarious ticker
symbols burlington universal replacement
parts stocks toledo ukulele
refurbishment and distribution
philadelphia occupational orthopedics
and prosthetics
and franklin unified consortium riveters
stocks thanks conan
now let's go back to conan o'brien for
our buy or buy
segment
conan would you buy these stocks or say
bye to them nokia buy stock buy
stock four five
wow conan you would buy all of them
no at least half of those were saying
goodbye to them wow
stocks stocks now it's time to give a
shout out to our sponsor
mind bulge
mind bulge the only brain increasing
supplement that will bulge your mind
mind balls they're not staring at your
bulge
they're staring at your mind mind bowl
is illegal in 50 states but it is legal
in the only state that counts
the state of your bulge available at bus
stops
and that's all for this episode of
cuckoo cash until next time
remember don't just count your blessing
count
your cash
[Music]